hallo ich bin vanessa die linse aber
hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
und es ist der zweite tag der
geburtstagswoche auf mal wann de nein es
gibt diese seite nicht denn am samstag
den neunten leuten habe ich geburtstag
und bis dahin gibt es jeden tag ein
neues video auf diesem kanal dafür
stehen bleiben und heute möchte ich euch
erzählen was ich mir zu meinem
geburtstag wünschen wir den weltfrieden
nein natürlich wünsche ich mir geld den
link zu meinem paypal konto findet ihr
unten in der video beschreibung bei
spenden über 50 euro erhalte die eine
dankeskarte mit widmung aber ich glaube
der mensch ist glücklich wenn er wünsche
und träume hat er mit einem ziel vor
augen haben wir einen weg auf dem wir
laufen können ansonsten irgendwie nur
wild auf einem feld der unbegrenzten
möglichkeiten um mein gott das habe ich
mir gerade selbst ausgedacht also nicht
gerade sondern verhindert sich auf
meinem balkon saß und das hier das war
fast schon auf dem studienband epische
moral abschlussrede niveau
schulterklopfer nein es soll ich machen
und nicht sagen da mein wohlbefinden
immer damit zusammen ob ich gerade ziel
habe oder nicht habe ich mir mal
ernsthafte gedanken darüber gemacht was
ich mir eigentlich wünschen oder come to
the switch lässt
ich würde gerne einmal nach schottland
reisen keine ahnung warum aber dieses
land hat es mir einfach angetan und
nicht nur wegen cent jugend wo sind
meine augen doch ich mag die vorstellung
davon in einem pakt zu sitzen und eine
wanderung durch die highlands zu machen
und plötzlich sind jugend zu treffen der
sich dann in mich verliebt irgendwann
möchte ich in einem haus mit großem
garten leben es muss kein super groß so
dass ba stylisches haus sein so ein haus
wie vom filmteam an
das war super ich will ja nicht angeben
aber letztes jahr habe ich in seinem
garten gesessen und mit ihm ein bier
getrunken also finden falls das haus ich
mir haben willst call me ein wunsch den
ich mir nicht mit geld erfüllen kann
aber dafür umso mehr tun muss ist meine
schlechten angewohnheiten loszuwerden
eigentlich finde ich dass man keine
schlechten angewohnheiten haben kann
sondern nur angewohnheiten aber mich
nervt es so sehr dass ich mir immer
hundert mal mehr sorgen machen als alle
anderen so wie kelly und mirella könnte
ich niemals durch die welt reisen meine
gedanken wurden sofort zu den ganzen
schlimme sachen wandern die alle
passieren könnten und das sind immer
ganz schön viele besonders wenn es so
nach afrika oder so geht dann denke ich
immer gleich an die impfung und was ist
wenn sich eine
lustig die dann dein leben beendet also
hoffe ich irgendwann den weg zu finden
um einfach mal irgendwann ganz entspannt
zu sein
rusal hans hab ich mir noch auf
beschrieben 100.000 follower auf
instagram ewige schönheit reichtum und
einen dicken buch also die 100 tausend
follower auf instagram das ist ein
realistischer wunsch oder mir jetzt mal
im ernst umso älter ich wurde desto
weniger wünsche hatte in meinem siebten
geburtstag habe ich mir einen malkasten
gewünscht kennt ihr das ding noch da war
einfach alles drin tusche wachsmalkreide
stifter und was hat das denn gekostet 10
euro und ich konnte nichts anderes
denken als an meinen malkasten und heute
weiß ich nicht mal was mein lieblings
eis ist warum wird man als erwachsener
so schwammig mit zwölf wusste ich alles
ganz genau in der eisdiele bestelle ich
eine kugel zitrone bei singstar sie
nicht definitiv superstar familie meine
lieblingsfarbe ist gelb wenn ich groß
bin werde ich einmal schauspielerin und
manchmal kommen aus dem schlafzimmer
meiner eltern so komische geräusche ja
wie sieht es bei euch mit wünschen aus
habt ihr ziele die erreichen wollt
wünscht ihr euch etwas so ganz vom
ganzen herzen lassen sie mich auf jeden
fall in den kommentaren wissen
vielleicht kann ich mich auch ein
bisschen inspirieren lassen und dann
habe ich vielleicht auch irgendwann mal
richtige wünsche und ziele in hamburg
will ich niemals haben würde ich mich
sofort auf die fresse packen ach ja und
vergesst nicht den paper link in der
video beschreibung also
[Musik]
i don't know who you are
hier könnt ihr klicken wenn ihr immer
schon mal wissen wollte wie die
geburtstagstorte von hackett an harry
potter geschmeckt hat und dort ist auch
irgendein random video was sich einfügen
werde und hier könnt ihr mich abonnieren
einmalige chance ihr könnt auf meine
brüste klicken und abonnieren
denn sex sells bitte nicht
monetarisieren danke tschüss